[Music]
when Warner Brothers Studios in the
Hollywood it's the konanov E&C Awards
celebrating excellence in the city and
looking ours here now is your host Conan
O'Brien
thank you no please sit back down that's
ridiculous to stick to stand twice in
one night what a crowd I can't believe I
get to host this and for a night that's
important I think I should dress the
part Bruce if you don't mind guys it's
this simple all right picture caller
what fix your collar
let me see uh what's the matter with it
it looks fine oh that yeah okay thanks a
lot Andy sure Rick I was subtle nobody
noticed that was a nice quiet fix on
your part to call any hoots it's the
audience the awards and no award is
complete without the actual statuette of
the audience see isn't that beautiful
look at that
[Music]
I don't know if this guy is clapping or
bragging
well what a crass guy he is I'm telling
you ladies settle down pal and put some
clothes on okay and get some genitalia
all right our first audience the award
is for the best impression of a
celebrity and the audience egos to the
person in seat 5d for their impression
of Jesse Eisenberg let's check it out
[Applause]
very Eisenberg ass very much so next RNC
goes to the person in seat 16 E it's the
award for most likely to kidnap William
Neeson's family check him out
[Music]
10% of Skittles even happy about it he's
happy hey think I took them all
I'm sure I'm messing with the right guy
all right this next audience he goes to
the person in seat 15 M
it's the award for the audience member
who just won the US Open tennis
tournament on his Nintendo Wii
[Music]
the next audience he goes to the person
in seat 9c it's the award for the
audience member most likely to be the
president of the National Association of
sexy vampires
[Music]
oh look she's covering the neck getting
ready to go back in the to next E&C goes
to the person in seat 11 K it's the
award for the audience member most
likely to spend six hours at Guitar
Center without actually buying anything
[Music]
okay it's okay I do it - it's alright
next audience he goes I play everyone
stairway to heaven on each one and then
leave the next audience he goes to the
person in seats 7l it's the award for
the audience member most likely to have
just sold his software company in
Microsoft for 3.2 billion dollars
[Music]
by the way we have a new sponsor for the
audience sees tonight isn't that right
Andy that's right Conan tonight's
audience he Awards are brought to you by
open bottle spring water I've already
opened it and taken this week so you
know it's good
oh that's good stuff yeah back to you
felon
you